a man may die
nations may rise and fall
but an idea lives on
mankind must put an end to war
or war will put an end to mankind
Freedom courage and morality are a big
part of every country and every single
person
listen to these quotes by John F Kennedy
to understand how you can change your
life today
change is the law of life
and those who look only to the past or
the present
are certain to miss the future
if freedom is to survive and prosper
it will require sacrifice the effort and
the thoughtful attention of every
citizen
Conformity is the Jailer of freedom and
the enemy of growth
art is not a form of propaganda
it is a form of Truth
we celebrate the past
to awaken the future
if a free Society cannot help the many
who are poor
cannot save the few who are rich
forgive your enemies
but never forget their names
those who dare to fail miserably can
achieve greatly
children are the world's most valuable
resource
and its best hope for the future
victory has a hundred fathers and defeat
is an orphan
if a free Society cannot help the many
who are poor
it cannot save the few who are rich
Rising tide lifts all boats
do not pray for easy lives
pray to be stronger men
we must use time as a tool
not
as a couch
the time to repair the roof is when the
sun is shining
the rights of every man are diminished
when the rights of one man are
threatened
if not us
who
if not now
when
leadership and learning are
indispensable to each other
a man may die
nations may rise and fall but an idea
lives on
one person can make a difference
and everyone should try
in serving his vision of the truth
the artist best serves his Nation
we must find time to stop and thank the
people who make a difference in our
lives
let us not emphasize all on which we
differ but all we have in common
let us consider not what we fear
separately
but what we share together
we cannot negotiate with people who say
what's mine is mine and what's yours is
negotiable
those who dare to fail miserably
can achieve greatly
a child miseducated
is a child lost
as we express our gratitude we must
never forget that the highest
appreciation is not to utter words
but to live by them
those who make peaceful Revolution
impossible
will make violent revolution inevitable
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade
and do the other things not because they
are easy
but because they are hard
for one true measure of a nation is its
success in fulfilling the promise of a
better life
for each of its members
the Supreme reality of our time
is the vulnerability of our planet
Conformity is the Jailer of freedom and
the enemy of growth
war will exist until that distant day
when the conscientious objector enjoys
the same reputation and prestige
as the warrior does today
in the Chinese language the word crisis
is composed of two characters
one representing danger and the other
opportunity
if more politicians do poetry
and more poets New Politics
I am convinced the world would be a
little better place in which to live
together let us explore the Stars
conquer the deserts eradicate disease
tap the ocean's depths and encourage the
Arts and Commerce
a woman quickly gives herself to the one
who she doesn't love
and resists the one she loves
because to the loved one
she wants to seem good
and with the unloved
she isn't ashamed to seem bad
a man does what he must in spite of
personal consequences in spite of
obstacles and dangers
and pressures
and that is the basis of all human
morality
a wise man will never tell a woman two
things his true feelings
and his balance account
the stories of past courage can teach
they can offer hope they can provide
inspiration
but they cannot Supply courage itself
for this each man must look into his own
soul
We the People
are the boss
and we will get the kind of political
leadership but be it good or bad
that we demand and deserve
we have collected the quotes by John F
Kennedy whose Legacy still lives on
though he spoke these words more than
five decades ago President Kennedy's
thoughts on freedom courage and morality
feel just as relevant today
thanks for watching